foreign
a makeshift shooting range breaks the
silence
for the do they have Battalion one of
the Chechen volunteer groups fighting
alongside Ukraine block arrived in the
country just two weeks ago he won't tell
us from where for security reasons
it's important for me because we have a
common enemy or people suffer greatly
because of the Russians just like the
ukrainians are now
the Battalion is named after johar
dudayev a Chechen leader who fought for
independence from Russia their mission
falls under the orders of the Ukrainian
Army but they are not formally under its
National command
when the Russians retreated from the
kharkiv region in the northeast of the
country they left behind a considerable
amount of military hardware and weapons
that heavy machine gun is one of them
and now they're training on it
units of the Battalion were among the
first to enter the Strategic city of
izum when the Russians were forced to
retreat
they also took part in the fight north
of Kiev battles that put them against
fellow chechens loyal to ramzan kadirov
the Chechen leader who publicly supports
Moscow his Fighters also took part in
the siege of marupal when the Russians
captured the Port City
Ukraine is a closed matter I wonder
about Poland Poland what are they trying
to achieve after Ukraine if the order is
given we will show you in six seconds
what we're capable of
kadirov has recently critical size
Russia's military strategy in Ukraine
but has also pledged tens of thousands
of men as part of moscow's mobilization
efforts that Russia is terrible for
small nation because now they're using
us as a cannon meat we always said forty
Chinese people attending by Russian here
we tell them that we are ready guys to
get you if you decide to hands up you
don't have to fight we're not asking
them to come Ukraine and fight for
Ukraine but we ask them not fight
against Ukraine
no many of the commanders here are
veterans of the two Chechen Wars that
reduce the capital grossly to what the
U.N called the most destroyed city on
earth
there's no Freedom no jobs young people
have no other choice but to join the
police or Armed Forces nothing is
produced before we used to have
refineries but they stopped everything
the oils go to Russia
the divisions among chechens fighting in
Ukraine are somehow a war within a war
for these men the ultimate goal is the
creation of the Chechen Republic of
ishkaria independent from moscow's
sphere of influence
in the key region